let's take some calls 617 830 4750 is
the number uh caller you're on the air
what's your name and where you calling
from hi this is kevin carr jose luis can
you hear me yeah Kevin what's going on
what's on your mind I did it about a
week or two ago you talked about the the
alternative right mm-hmm I believe in a
video yeah and it was a pretty different
I'd say you really nailed it but I did
have one question about it and that's
you talked about dinner date being part
of the old right um is that really
something you believe I mean you've
talked a lot of gamergate people so do
you think that we're all right or no no
so I think that you're you misunderstood
what what i said so i listed gamergate
in a list of movements that generally
the alt right is supportive of so i
think you have it sort of exactly
backwards okay so you think that the
other supports gamergate looking great
people don't necessarily support the old
right yes that is much closer to what it
is that we said in the video and you
know I don't know a bunch of people have
asked me to take back a comment i never
made it so I'm glad that now you've
presented the opportunity to actually
clarify what was said you'd think it
would just be a matter of going back and
listening to the video a second time but
many people apparently misunderstanding
at once and then demanding a correction
for something that I'd never said in the
first place well thank you David for
clarifying I'm actually going to reflect
on my own committed a video sort of
responding to you but i'm going to edit
edit that and put a notification about
your comment okay all right very good
really appreciate it thank you so much
for the call always good to clarify pat
if nothing else what was and was not set